Come in closer.
Because the more you think you see,...
...the easier it will be to fool you.
Ladies and gentlemen!
For our final trick...
We are going to rob a bank.
On the count of three you will be teleported through space and time...
...to your bank in Paris.
One,..
...two,...
...three.
Everyone in this room was a victim of hard times.
Some of you lost your home, your car...
And so tonight,...
We're gonna return some of that money back to you.
Thank you, everyone.
Good night!
Freeze!
Hands where I can see them.
Can you explain to me how you went from Las Vegas to Paris in three seconds?
What do the kids call it these days?
Oh, magic.
I'm gonna nail your ass.
First rule of magic:...
...always be the smartest guy in the room.
Your bank was the distraction.
Now they set up the real trick.
Expose them now and destroy them.
Hang on, hang on.
I've got nothing.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you for the delay.
Whatever this grand trick is,...
...it was designed a long time ago.
And I believe that what's about to follow...
...is really going to amaze.
Look closely, because the closer you think you are,...
...the less you'll actually see.